bonjour je m'appelle agè Jaoui et je
vais commenter des archives de
Lina bonjour agè Jaoui ah bonjour alors
le cinéma c'est votre univers vous êtes
comédienne scénariste et réalisatrice
vous chantez chanteuse et chanteuse bien
sûr vous chantez aussi et vous donnez de
la voix pour des causes qui vous
semblent justes nous allons dialoguer
avec les figures qui ont inspiré votre
vie de femme d'Artist et de militante
alors pour commencer une actrice qui a
marqué sa génération
la beauté d'abord une chose qui passe
est une chose sur laquelle on nous
apprend beaucoup à compter et sur
laquelle on nous apprend pas enfin on
nous apprend aussi qu'on la jette à un
certain moment donné la beauté parce
qu'elle passe parce qu'elle est plus
égale à elle-même ma célébrité elle est
du au plus grand des hasards et à
l'appui certainement
de des hommes je crois que on doit les
actrices sont dépendantes comme comme
toutes les autres de
du règne des hommes je suis le type de
l'esclave je sais exactement ce que
c'est que l'image que les hommes veulent
avoir des femmes moi à partir du moment
où je m rends compte et où je le dis je
deviens quelqu'un de très antipathique
pour les hommes c'est c'est drôle c'est
c'est c'est des extraits qu'on a qu'on a
découvert relativement récemment en tout
cas moi mais j'ai l'impression un peu
tout le monde et c'est et c'est une des
choses qui m'a le plus déprimé je dois
dire dans ces dernières années de
militantisme de féminisme actif c'està
dire que j'ai juste envie d'avoir les
mêmes droits que les hommes pas beaucoup
plus ces discours de Delphin serig et
puis d'autres bien avant pratiquement
depuis le début de
l'humanité ne sont pas relayés on parle
de première vague de deuxème vague de
féminisme et cetera mais en fait c'est
un sujet qui occupe les les femmes et
les hommes depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps bien sûr mais à chaque fois
c'est
recouvert chaque chaque lutte chaque
avancée chaque prise de conscience est
recouvert par bah la pensée dominante et
donc réoublier c'est dingue des des
compositrices des des des peintteresses
des alors certes il y en avait moins d'
mais il y en avait des des des des
autrices et cetera elles sont effacées
quoi elles sont effacées elles sont pas
mise en valeur l'histoire est écrite par
les vainqueurs et on peut transmettre
des mémoires qui ne sont qui sont pas
justes il y a eu des femmes
gladiatrices je l'ai découvert à un
musée de nî mais c'est incroyable enfin
voilà enfin bon
c'est c'est ce côté il faut toujours
recommencer et puis et puis rien n'est
jamais acquis à la femme on va écouter
une autre femme maintenant avec qui vous
avez plusieurs points communs votre nom
votre amour des arts et du cinéma et
aussi une pluie de récompense pour le
moment on fait ce qu'on peut hein on
nage comme on peut on fait des films et
alors je crois que il faut se dire voilà
ça va s'accumuler comme ça et puis quand
ira des centaines de films de femmes on
va bien voir qu'il y a des films form
làdedans et puis et puis et puis celles
qui viennent je veux dire elles vont
être
peut-être encore plus doué par le fait
que ça va devenir si naturel ça va
devenir il y aura tellement moins l'idée
c'est un film de femmes qui doit se
faufiler et cetera puis il y aura des
femmes dans toutes les dans tous les
postes quand j'ai commencé il y a 30 ans
il y avait entre il y avait 20 % de
femmes réalisatrices en France dans les
autres pays c'était 1 % 2 % 3 % bon bref
donc on était et puis après jusqu'à 2021
en tout cas on était à 22 % 23 % enfin
il y avait pas t d'évolution dans dans
dans la réalisation des films fait par
des femmes je sais pas pourquoi on n'est
pas à 50 % quoi c'est ça que je veux
dire ça fait très longtemps que dans les
écoles de cinéma on est à 50 % puis
qu'après c'est plus le cas et la
télévision Delphin ARN a bien vient de
enfin il y a 2 ou 3 ans a dit qu'elle
qu'elle exigeit un quota de 30 % de de
films réalisés par des femmes euh bah
c'est c'est bien mais c'est mais c'est
bizarre quand même ça veut dire que 70 %
toujours sont réalisés par des hommes
continue à parler de film de femm la
journée de la femme non ça ça ça ça
bouge lentement franchement les
résistances sont innombrables on va
regarder un homme cette fois qui qui a
beaucoup compté dans votre carrière
cinématographique on va l'écouter parler
sur des images du tournage de son film
Mon oncle d'Amérique an Ren n'aime pas
du tout répondre à des questions devant
une caméra mais il a bien voulu parler
de son film devant un
magnétophoneou j'ai l'impression que la
fabrication d'un film c'est une telle
suite de coïncidence et de hasard j'ai
presque l'impression par un moment que
le point de départ est est indifférent
je veux dire que pour qu'un producteur
des comédiens un scénariste un metteur
en scène arrive à se retrouver sur un
projet commun il faut
euh tellement oui de coïncidence que
quand le film est fini c'est même
quelquefois difficile d'arriver à les
reconstituer il a raison et il est
modeste les films de Renet c'est les
films de Renet quoi enfin il y a pas de
donc il doit y avoir des hasards qui
sont quand même un peu orientés ce qui
est vrai c'est que et c'est ce qui est
bon
enfin c'est que c'est c'est tout le
temps en mouvement c'est un long
processus et qu'effectivement vous
pouvez pas tout prévoir du tout au
contraire enfin voilà c'est et c'est ça
moi que j'aime en même temps j'ai appris
à ses côtés j'ai
appris des saut sur le son beaucoup sur
le découpage sur la façon de faire des
plans séquences et puis aussi sur sa
bonté enfin sur sa façon d'obtenir
beaucoup de choses des gens mais avec
toujours une infinie douceur et un
respect absolu alors justement on va
vous montrer une archive d'un d'un
cinéaste qui n'était pas doux du tout
bon j'ai pas le temps d'attendre hein
moi on va le faire muer
écoutez ça devient mais écoutez il le
perchem n'est pas là tu te rends compte
mais c'est une plaisanterie ça allez
tournons
AR qu'est-ce qu'il fout ce con qu'est-ce
que tu fous là-bas viens là nom de Dieu
oh mais qu'est-ce que tu as les
là-haut allez moteur vite vite il a le
soleil qui va sortir mes enfants allez
moteur
moteur vite au départ allez allez allez
allez mur dans 30 secondes on raccorde
absolument allez moteur allons-y mteur
vas-y vas-y Jean-Pierre mteur mteur
allons-y
[Applaudissements]
monteur je pense que CIT pas le pire du
tout mais bon bref effectivement c'est
oui je pense que c'est un des rares
métier o on peut insulter enfin il y a
plein de comportements qui seraient qui
seraient acceptés dans sur
aucun aucune autre entreprise je pense
mais est-ce que dans ces cas-là la fin
justifie les moyens c'estàd qu'il y a
des réalisateurs non mais non pas pour
moi bien sûr que non non je pense qu'on
peut faire des grands films sans sans
mettre une tension énorme et sans être
violent et sans sans maltraiter les gens
alors là moi c'est c'est quelque chose
qui m'est absolument insupportable donc
non il y a rien qui justifie rien du
tout c'est c'est pas rare j'avais
travailler avec un un cinéaste et un M
en scène de théâtre qui qui qui é qui
était pas doux qui était très
que voilà lui qui a l'air mignon comme
ça he parce que on le voit pas mais quel
souvenir vous gardez de ce passage aux
amandier un très mauvais souvenir je
garde un souvenir d'avoir connu ce que
c'était que la dictature avec un
dictateur et et des gens qui deviennent
lâche qui perdent le sens commun parce
que parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a le
pouvoir sur les autres et et d'autres
qui s'y soumettent voilà est-ce que vous
méritez votre succès bien sû cette
question a été posée à Jean-Pierre Baker
en
1986 qu'est-ce qu'il a
répondu Jean-Pierre Baker méritez-vous
votre succès si je pense le
mériter on verra ça plus tard et vos
quatre partenaires pensez-vous qu'il le
mérite leur
succès on verra ça plus
tard quel est le rôle que vous auriez
rêvé
d'interpréter toute l'histoire du cinéma
Scarlette
dansorte le vent après 10 film vous
connaissez les CL de
Ré pas celle du garage déjà
mais le la sincérité et
l'intégrité sincérité pour mon métier
l'intégrité dans ma vie c'est marrant
parce que vous remarquerez
c'estre mais la journaliste
ne ne change pas de registre et il n'est
pas question qu'elle sourit et qu'elle
prenne pas au premier degré toutes les
réponses de Jean-Pierre et je crois que
savoir qu'ils avaient d'ailleurs dit ah
non mais là on rigole pas c'est cinéma
cinéma enfin vraiment il fallait pas et
c'est drôle d'ailleurs he ce ce cette
peur du rire et du comicque qu'ont
certains intellectuels Cinéfil vous avez
écrit pendant 30 ans avec lui ouais et
aujourd'hui l'écriture ça donne quoi
j'écris différemment j'écris
euh j'écris j'écris seul et puis je vais
écrire avec avec d'autres voilà avant de
connaître Jean-Pierre Bakri vous avez
commencé à écrire enfant par peur de la
mort vous avez expliqué on écoute un
réalisateur qui vous a inspiré en parler
vous créez autant pour échapper à notre
angoisse à tous hein certains
l'expriment d'autres pas euh ce qui
s'appelle tout simplement l'angoisse de
la mort
oui c'est la chose la plus importante au
monde toute not toute notre
vie se passe se déroule face à ce
problème ce dilemme certains passent
leur temps en gagnant beaucoup d'argent
d'autres comm des
[Musique]
suicides d'autres
essatteindre l'immortalité par
l'artêre éternel en construisant
mais les gens se lancent dans des
religions diverses et
variées c'est aussi absurde mais elles
ils sont terrifiés et et et c'est ce
qu'ils
font et donc toute votre vie se centre
autour de ce problème c'estàd que c'est
une drôle de règle du jeu quand même de
savoir qu'on qu'on va tous mourir de
tous savoir qu'on va mourir et et de
vivre en attendant ce jour où on
l'attendant pas et ce qui est très
bizarre aussi c'est là de vivre en se
disant que peut-être là on va tous
mourir tous en même temps ou en tout cas
pays par pays avec ce ce ce dérèglement
climatique et on fait comme si pas j'ai
entendu dans vos interviews que vous
disiez j'ai j'ai commencé à écrire petit
enfant parce que j'avais peur de mourir
est-ce que vous faites de l'art parce
que vous avez peur de mour j'avais pas
peur j'ai pas seulement peur de mourir
non non j'avais j'avais peur que que je
Meur et que personne ne sache que j'ai
existé euh c'est c'est dans ce sens-là
euh donc j'avais
oui un un un un un besoin de et c'est
pour ça que le journal d'Anne Franck
m'avait autant marqué je me disais mais
cette cette cet enfant euh enfin cette
jeune fille a existé parce que parce que
ce journal a été retrouvé et
elle a au combien existé donc euh donc
je me suis mise à écrire mon journal je
me suis mise à à imaginer tout ce qui
était possible pour euh pour pour qu'on
soit sûr que que j'ai existé parce que
j'aurais pu faire d'autres choses pour
euh pour marquer mon époque je sais pas
quoi euh la politique plein d'autres
trucs mais euh mais l'art euh enfin je
trouve que compte que c'est
mieux que la vie est mieux en musique la
vie est mieux quand on invente des
histoires la vie est mieux quand euh
quand on réfléchit à ce qu'elle est euh
quand euh
quand on partage cette passion avec
d'autres ça fait du bien à autre chose
que peut-être je partage avec c'estd
certaine dépression quo fond dépressif
certain en tout
casège beaucoup pour moi toute forme
[Musique]
d'art centr dans vos films pour en
parler nous Alina on a décidé de
convoquer une personne qui n'a pas
grandchose à voir avec le cinéma quoique
j'essaie de de de montrer que dans les
classements sociaux que nous opérons
quand nous mettons une cravate nous
mettons pas une cravate quand nous
mettons une cravate à poids une cravate
unie quand nous achetons une Mercedes ou
une de chevaux quand nous faisons du du
du yoga ou ou du
rugby et cetera tous les choix que nous
faisons qui à ordinaire sont sont
imputés au goût et aux couleurs enfin ce
sont ces choses qu'on imput au fond à la
nature en fait je pense que toutes ces
tous ces choix ont leur principes dans
la société dépendent d'une part de notre
de notre formation notre éducation de
l'ancienneté de notre éducation de notre
milieu notre capital scolaire et ceter B
oui je suis entièrement d'accord avec
lui je crois que j'avais pas du tout lu
Bourdieu avant qu'on écrive le goût des
autres c'est les gens qui m'ont parlai
le premier une journaliste japonaise je
me rappelle ça me passionne la
sociologie et aussi la psychologie la
psychanalyse voilà enfin c'est c'est je
trouve que c'est des gris lecture qui se
complète mais oui oui ça me fascine à
quel point il est dur de changer à quel
point même quand on identifie ses
défauts ou son habitus ou c'est quel
point est difficile de de s'en sortir
ouis c'était une fascination qui était
aussi partagée avec Jean-Pierre Baker
vous partagez aussi des colère avec
lui lui comme vous n'hésitez pas à
donner sa personne pour une cause qui
lui semblait juste regardez tous les
comédiens les artistes que l'on voit
s'engager de CAES humanitair charitable
ou
politique vous en êtes certains disent
les comédiens n'ont pas affiché leur
mais certains certains certains c'est un
con vous êtes bien au courant de
ça vous savez que c'est comme ça que ça
marche moi je moi moi je dis que si ça
aide je joue le jeu volontiers très
volontiers parce que ça c'est une forme
de putasserie qui me plaît bien moi moi
je veux bien faire la pour la pour
humanitairement je veux bien faire la
ça me dérange pas du tout
je la connaissais pas cette archive
euh benah oui oui je je je suis d'accord
avec lui enfin j'aurais peut-être pas
pris l'expression faire la mais euh
disons que si si notre petite célébrité
peut peut aider alors par contre lui
comme moi on éétait pas toujours sur
d'aider euh souvent notamment aux hommes
et aux femmes leur dit je suis pas sûr
que mon a pu vous aidere beaucoup le
côté le Paris qui chant quiid Dan qui
ensemble disent qu'il faut faire pour
qui vaut voter ça peut être totalement
repoussoir et d'ailleurs on voit bien
ces dernières années le yatus qu'il y a
entre ceux qui s'expriment à la
télévision et le vote de de la rue ou du
peuple donc plus ça va plus j'aime aller
aussi à la rencontre de des vrais gens
partout et discuter et me confronter à
eux prêcher des convaincus c'est pas
toujours passionnant bon on est beaucoup
écouter de gens parler dans les archives
c'est le moment d'écouter une
chanson j'ai quitté mon
[Musique]
pays j'ai quitté ma
maison ma vie ma triste vie se traîne
sans
[Musique]
raison j'ai quitté mon
soleil
j'ai quitté ma mère
bleu leur souvenir se
réveill bien après mon
adieu
soleil soleil de mon pays
perdu des villes blanches que
j'aimais vous l'avez chanté avec lui
cette chanson
soleil soleil de mon pays
perdu
des villes blanches que
j'aimis des filles que j'ai jadis
Conn j'ai pas connu la Tunisie enfant je
l'ai connu à travers ce que raconai mes
parents et à travers oui les les les
shabbat les dîners les les couscous et
et tout ce que m'ont transmis mes
parents et ma famille mais malgré tout
je me sens un lien extrêmement fort
avec la Tunisie avec ces pays-là mais
avec j'ai un peu reconstituer ça à Cuba
en fait plutôt c'est là que j'ai
retrouvé la Tunisie de mes parents et
puis pareil c'est comme tout dans la vie
au fur et à mesure des années j'étais
amené à y retourner il y a un projet de
film là-bas de My banatia il y a il y a
des nouvelles générations de tunisiennes
il y en a une avec laquelle aussi je
collabore sur des chansons qui s'appell
Nael crayen et tout ça aussi chemine
alors là on voit des images d'un Kibo ah
c'est un Kibo je pensais que c'était
ouais est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs
de votre passage dans un kibbo quand
vous étiez enfant ah bah j'ai passé tous
mes étés donc j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
du kibutradort et ça m'a évidemment
aussi beaucoup marqué on y allait avec
mon frère tout enfin mes parents tout
les étai puis mes parents partaient et
nous laissai chez ma grand-mère et puis
après dans la goutza avec les bref on on
a j'y suis allé jusqu'à mes 15 ans donc
bien sûr
que que cétait particulier que ça m'a
marqué que
c'était intéressant est-ce que vous
aimez la nostalgie
oui
oui plus tard vous êtes tombé amoureux
d'une autre musique une musique joyeuse
mais nostalgique aussi on écoute comp
segundo le PAP de la musique
cubaine
je suis un journaliste un écrivain un
messager de la
[Musique]
joie je suis un jeune
homme parce que je pratique une jolie
chose la
musique et je
mourrai écrivant et chantant la
musique
c'est la joie et puis c'est la douceur
en fait c'est un peuple quand même
particulièrement doux très attachant et
qui crève là en ce moment c'est terrible
[Applaudissements]
voil c'est une musique qui ressemble
aussi à la musique Arab andalouse
beaucoup beaucoup ce qui est beau dans
la musique c'est à quel point elle
voyage à quel point euh elle se mélange
elle se
elle s'enrichit des cultures les unes
les autres quoi c'est c'est ce qu'il y a
de plus beau sur terre je pense la
musique c'est la plus grande réussite de
des
humains alors c'est le moment pour moi
d'arrêter de vous poser des questions je
vais vous laisser le soin de décider qui
va le faire à ma place vous avez le
choix entre Philippe Bouvard Caroline
Tresca Henry Chapier et de Denise Glazer
alors Denise Glazer sans
hésitation est-ce que vous savez
réellement pourquoi vous faites ce que
vous faites j'en ai parlé pas mal là
pendant cette
demi-heure j'ai quelques idées sur
Pourquoi je fais ce que je fais oui
merci an
Jaoui